- Hello, people, it's
Louis again, Big Lou.
For all of the emotional
appeal seldom suffices.
For I know when I come down here,
and tell you guys a story, for you guys
to identify with them, they've
got to have depth and weight.
That means I got to tell the truth
from the bone to the heart.
So I come down and I lay it on y'all,
I'll give it to you just like it is.
I thinking about some nouns I had learned
when I was about five years old.
Stupid, dumb, worthless,
idiot, dumbest dummie
of all fuckin' dummies.
Those were the words I
heard when I was a kid,
those were the nouns that they gave me,
the names that they gave
me when I was a kid.
And to this day, to this very day,
them fuckin' nouns walk with me.
I mean I lay down at night
and I think about them
and they bring up things
that occurred in my life,
and sometimes I wonder whether
the things that occurred
in my life, were they pertaining to
what I was called and whatnot.
I don't know, I don't
know political science
or anything like that.
One of the stories that
I was thinking about
that happened to me,
and I was always trying to tell things
that I don't wanna tell,
I'm gonna tell you what I
don't wanna tell you first,
I really don't wanna tell anybody this,
because I have never, ever,
ever, told anybody this.
Well, Line L trains, have always been my,
I love me a Line L train,
I've always been crazy
about Line L trains,
well anyway, I've always been crazy
about Southern Pacific Trains,
because Southern Pacific
trains would always
come through the neighborhood and do,
the raggedy neighborhood we lived in.
And momma used to take me
down to the tracks sometimes
and I would sit there in the car,
I would just love to watch
them go across that track.
(train clacking)
When they go across,
I just loved to watch them fuckin' trains.
So, one time, we was,
I had some friends that we
used to hang around with,
and we had a guy who used to tell us,
urban legends and stories,
and we used to always love to
listen to him tell stories.
One day he sat down and he said,
well man, you, you like these,
you seem like these trains
that got a train show coming
over there in the tent next week,
you know, me and my friend,
he wants to take you over to the trains,
so you can watch the trains.
So he takes me to the train.
So we get there, and man,
they've got a train there that
goes on top of the ceiling
going around, they got a passenger train,
they got a Southern Pacific
train going around them,
and they've got a Santa Fe,
a little blue and gold Santa Fe train
that ran along the bottom there.
So I'm watching trains,
and I'm thinking about,
I must be six or seven years old
and I was watching trains.
So this white guy is looking at me,
he's kinda got his eye on me.
So I'm a little kid, I didn't know what
was going on, you know.
And they couldn't get me out of there,
because when I'm really,
to turn it back a little bit,
my mom took me to a car show one time,
and she didn't have enough but
to get me and my brother in there.
She put me in there and I
stayed in the fucking place
for 11 hours, didn't
think nothing about them.
I stayed in that place for 11 hours
and my mother was so mad at me,
and her and my brother
had to stand out there
and wait on me, so when I get into it,
I was into the trains like that.
So my friends left me there at the tent.
But there's this white guy man,
and he's just insisting that I would come,
he's like, well I see you like
the freight train up here,
and you like the Santa Fe train, and so,
well I got a couple of
trains at home, man.
You wanna come by the house
and look at some trains?
We dropped the tent, and my dumb ass,
something told me, something told me,
something in my back of my mind told me,
don't get in that car with
that man I don't know.
I got in that car anyway.
And we went to his house.
And he had the trains,
and we had the trains,
and he had I remember it was like that,
that Nesle Quick chocolate milk,
I remember it like it was yesterday
He had some chocolate milk
that he gave me, I'm just, oh,
it's gonna be hard for
me to get this one out.
Because this is a tough one.
How do you get off of it?
So, he had one train that
ran in a figure eight
that ran along the floor.
And he told me, he said well,
one of the little wheels
had come off the track,
and he said, well bend down there
and get the wheel off the track.
I got down there, got
the wheel off the track.
And I should've known,
he was kind moving up
in his chair, you know, but
I'm a kid, I don't know nothing
about no man messing with me,
or none of that kind of shit.
So I remember I'm holding
the chair and I remember,
oh my god, he grabbed me by the,
he grabbed me by the neck like this,
and he pulled me up like this,
and he said, pull your pants
down, pull your pants down.
And I'm like, what?
Why? No!
He said pull your fucking,
pull your pants down.
So he made me pull my pants down.
And he tried to sodomize me.
But his penis, wouldn't,
oh God, I can't believe I'm telling this,
but his penis wouldn't fit in there,
he tried to sodomize me.
And as we got through, the way he had me,
he had me by the neck like this,
and through the leg some kind of way,
and in some kind of
way, I slipped through,
I slipped out, and I remember
when I ran out the door,
he told me, he said, if you
ever tell anybody what I did,
he said I'm gonna bring you back here,
and I'm gonna cut your ass,
he said I'm gonna cut your asshole open,
or something, whatever he told me,
he scared the shit out of me.
So I ran all the way home.
I ran home, I ran home,
must've been a mile or two,
I ran all the way home, and I
live down south at the time.
And I never told anybody.
I was, I was, I would
take that to the grave.
I thought that I would, I heard all these,
what made me said, I thought
about all these things
that they called me.
I said well maybe that's
why this guy tried to.
But I was so young, I didn't know why,
but it scared me to death.
I didn't know what the
fuck, I didn't know anything
about a serial killer or a murderer,
maybe that guy was a serial
killer or a murderer,
I don't know.
But I remember, he said,
I wouldn't tell anybody, because
I remembered what he said,
I thought he was gonna catch
me and cut me up or something.
So one day I was--
my father's side of the family,
the black people are white.
They're all like high
white class white people,
driving nice cars.
But the black people on my momma's side,
they all nigger, I mean they niggers.
She got some brothers
that need mother fuckers.
She got, whew, she got three brothers,
and these son of a bitch,
when they walk down the street,
motherfuckers move out the way.
I'm talking about, they get
out the mother fuckin' way,
and I ain't bullshitting.
So anyway, they happened
to be in my house that day,
and this is about six months later.
And this had bothered me,
this had really fucking
bothered me you know,
I mean come on man,
I'm a six year old kid.
Some man tried to put his
fucking penis in my ass,
I didn't know what the hell was going on.
And anyway, this particular guy,
and there was a bunch
of, it was down south,
they were a bunch of drunks
and now I know they were drunks,
because I'm a drunk.
But they would all hang out,
it was some black guys and some white guys
and they would all hang
out down on the corner
at this little convenience store.
It was the Pigggly Wiggly store.
And they would hang out there in front
and they would drink beer
and they would chill out in front
with them little Ford green truck,
one of them had a a lime green truck.
But anyway, my uncle said,
what's wrong with you boy?
I started crying, you know.
I just sitting there crying.
My uncle said, what's wrong with you boy?
I said nothing, I'm stuck in here.
I'm stuck in here, so all
day long he was asking me.
What's wrong with you man?
What's wrong with you,
what's wrong with you?
And I broke down and cried, I cried,
I couldn't stop crying.
I said this man, this man tried
to put his thing up my butt.
Now, I'm glad I told them.
But when I tell you what
my uncles did to him.
Now, let me get to the story.
I never will forget the
expression on my uncle's face.
He said, what the fuck you say?
As this motherfucker, he
called his other two brothers,
'cause they was all living with mom.
He said, get yo' ass in the truck,
we finna go find the motherfucker.
I'm like okay, yeah,
we gonna get him back.
I don't know, I thought they
were just gonna cuss him out,
or say, hey man, don't
fuck with my nephew.
But I knew, these guys, they're so big,
they could look at you man,
and you'll fucking shit.
My uncle, if they stand
up and look at you,
you gon' straight shit your pants.
I mean it's some big, big motherfuckers.
So anyway, we ridin' around this truck
and I'm buying ice cream,
and I'm scared to death and I'm shaking,
'cause I'm thinking what the guy told me,
he was gonna fucking kill me,
and I'm thinking, I'm
gonna die, I'm gonna die,
I'm gonna die.
And all that went by was,
'cause at first we couldn't find them.
And I'm happy we couldn't find him,
because now I don't have
to be reliable for tellin'.
I figured my uncles are
gonna forget about it,
and everything was gonna be gone about it.
We went around to the Piggly Wiggly store.
There the motherfucker was.
Him and three other white
boys were standing there.
And I remember, my uncle was driving,
he was on this side and
he slowed the truck down
and I looked, he looked at
me, and I guess I don't know,
when my uncle slowed the truck down,
you could hear one of
'em say, fucking niggers.
That's all she wrote.
My uncle said, I said, that's him.
My uncle went around the corner,
he parked the pickup truck.
He said, I'm gonna wait
'til I see this motherfucker
all by his self.
You should've seen the
expression on my face.
You should've saw the
tears, I was shaking,
I was so fucking scared, I
was in the truck shaking,
'cause I didn't know
what was gonna happen.
I vague remember, they
caught him by his self.
They beat him in the face.
My uncles put him in the
back of the pickup truck,
put a pair of handcuffs on his arms.
Hogtied his legs.
And we went, there was
a barn that a couple
of houses down from where
the Piggly Wiggly was,
and I guess they stored they
milk and shit when they got it.
And they grabbed this
man out of his truck.
Oh my God, that scene,
and they drug him in that barn,
and they, God I've
never told anybody this.
Nobody can't go to jail,
nobody knows my uncles.
They had a table laid out on the table.
They put him on that fuckin' table.
My uncle had a, not the
Louisville slugger, the short one.
Shew, I can still hear that man screaming.
And they hit him in the
face, he kept hitting him,
he was beating him, and he was just,
my mother fuckin' nephew,
did you fuck my--
he said no, no, no, no, no.
That wasn't me, it wasn't me.
And my uncle was hitting
him in the face man.
And every time he hit him, man I was just,
his face was turning blue and shit.
He fucked up and said, yeah I did it,
fuck you and that little nigger.
God I don't even know if
I can tell this, okay.
My uncle had a, in the
back of his pickup truck,
he had a, the kind of broom
that had a stick that goes like this.
I'm trying to figure out,
what the, he already
beat him with the bat.
What's he gon'--.
He took the stick and he
broke the tip of the stick.
And he pulled that
man's pants down and put
that stick in that man's ass.
And God, I could still hear that man.
I had never heard a man scream like that
'cause he was so far in the
barn couldn't nobody see him.
And what made it so bad, God
I never told anybody this.
God don't let me go to jail.
My uncle had a mallet and he said,
you will never ever try
to fuck another kid.
You never trying to mess with
mine nor no one else's nephew.
He said, why did you, why
my nephew, why my nephew,
why my nephew, why my nephew?
He said I don't know, I don't
know, fuck it, do what you--
and My uncle took that mallet
and he hit him two times in
the ass with that mallet.
Oh my God, I can still
see the blood coming
from his ass, man.
Blood shot out his ass,
like squirting out,
and that man, I've never
heard a man holler like that.
That man was hollering like
a three year old child,
I know somebody had to hear him.
And the fucked up thing about it was.
He was handcuffed and hogtied by the feet,
and they left him there to this day.
To this day!
I don't know if he died, if he did die,
nobody ever said a damn thing about it.
So, you know, that happened
to me for six months.
For six months after that.
I would say for about five,
six months after that,
I didn't say a word, you
couldn't get me to say hi.
Because they had a
saying when I was little,
they said sticks and
stones can break my bones,
but words can never hurt me.
And I knew if even though
that man did that to me.
I've always been a wuss,
but to see that stick go up
his ass like that, God damn.
I kinda felt sorry but
I never forgot that.
So I said if I can say
something to somebody
and then it make somebody
kill somebody like that
and I had to watch that
shit as a fucking six,
seven year old child, I need
not talk no fuckin' more.
I shut down.
They had to take me to a psych,
because they couldn't figure
out what was wrong with me.
I had saw a man get sliced by the ass
with a stick and a God damn
mallet all because he tried
to put his shit in my damn ass.
Now you know by then, as
young as a child as I was,
I was fucked up by that shit.
That long with the
women making me do shit,
and all the other shit with my
family making me do this shit
so that made me kind of call the--
but I think even through
that kind of shit, now,
even though that shit still affects me.
I think I didn't do too bad,
because it didn't drive
me all the way crazy.
Though I do have my moments
where, I do have my moments,
sometimes people make me
so mad doing little bitty shit
'til I wanna hurt 'em real bad.
I mean I just wanna--
I think about that kind of
shit and shit people did
to me when I was little,
and I wanna hurt 'em real fuckin' bad.
I wanna do some damage to mother fuckers.
I just wanna, I've never, I think it.
I think it in my mind.
I be sitting there
thinking, mother fucker,
you don't know what happened
to me when I was little.
I said you're talking,
you don't know who you fucking talk to.
Because I'm the kind of mother fucker.
I watch these programs on TV,
and there's these guys,
they're fucking serial killers.
And I'm thinking, that good lookin' kid,
how could he do that?
But then when they go back and tell,
I think that's why I like
those stories so much,
I watch them on TV,
because when they go back
and the psychologist get ahold of them
before they lock them up,
before they kill them,
they wanna know, and some of those guys
are bold like me, they'll
get out there and tell it.
The guy said when I was a little boy,
my father used to, one
kid said he used to watch
his father fuck his little
sister and he made him watch,
and he made him then tag
along, and that kind of shit,
but then we would grow up
and he would stab the animals
used to cut the animals up,
and that made that guy turn
into a fucking serial killer.
So sometimes I think like that.
I say there's nothing wrong with me,
because he thought like that.
I think like that too man,
I be wanting to fucking.
Some of the shit that I
think about doing to people.
I don't so much think about
doing shit so much now,
because I'm not finna
go get locked up behind
no motherfucking bars.
But this shit leads all the way up
into my alcoholism, when they
first offered me that joint,
I took that joint, I took that joint
and I got cool, calm, when
they hand me that drink,
I drink the whole bottle, threw up,
wanted another one.
Hey this is why I drink.
This is my medication,
this where I can kinda,
I can medicate.
I can push this shit down,
and I can drown it in there
and I never got to worry about it,
even though the pain's in there,
the pain ain't never going away.
It ain't never gon' go away.
But the pain is still
down in there, you know?
Oh, that was a deep one.
That was real hard to get off of,
but I feel a whole lot better.
- [Interviewer] Good job.
- Let me roll on before I start crying.
Because I didn't deserve that.
I didn't deserve that,
no fuckin' kid deserves
to get hammered in the ass and then
to watch somebody get half way killed.
No kid deserve no shit like that.
I mean I walk with this shit day.
But I told somebody I got
off of it, thank you, Jesus.
That wasn't too bad, was it?